I know that we haven't been dating super
long but we have been sheltering in
place together so I thought it might be
the time for us to take the next step in
a relationship he was the next step
sharing reusable toilet paper oh okay
I'm Steve and I'm Ari and we're gonna
try it and I use toilet paper for a
whole week and use reusable toilet paper
instead hikes I've been through a waste
since 2016 and I've never been so always
a single day of my life so I ordered a
good day okay and then how it's gonna
work is we're gonna put the bidet on the
toilet and then we're gonna use these
cloths so instead of toilet paper you
use those cloths I don't know how many
are in there hey that doesn't seem like
a lot yeah so then after you use the
wipe then you put it into this wet bag
so you reuse these yeah you reuse them
so you clean you clean them like a no
laundry yeah okay are you ready for this
oh yeah okay we're here at this point
there's no kind of in families no well
I'm pretty crunchy but when I heard
about reasonable toilet paper for the
first time I thought that was super
gross but after this pandemic started
it's been really hard to find toilet
paper it's almost become like a symbol
of this pandemic and so I thought that
this would actually be a good time to
give reusable toilet paper the shot
since you're staying with me you're also
going to be trusted
kind of weird because we use pastry just
like attaches onto the toilet and then
it like have you ever Easter the day no
do you know what it does no this is like
little nozzle and it sprays your bind
why are you doing it all yourself are
not the handyman in the relationship I
don't know what do you think solid job
oh my god it's actually not that hard to
install I got you like right there
that's so funny haha and there now yeah
your to spray me
yeah I've gotten Steve to try various
like eco-friendly things throughout our
relationship but I think this is
definitely the most extreme one and I
wonder if it's gonna put a strange Oh
doesn't get any more strange than this I
mean it potentially could what's the
next thing that I tried they woke up
actually so are he's been in the
bathroom yeah was it my nervous not
talking but yes it was very clean inside
I actually feel cleaner than usual it's
like super soft but I the one you use
it's in the wet bag the bidet had
cleaned everything so there was it was
completely clean when I I thought that
the day from trishy
and the wet bag from Amazon a wet bag is
used to put things like some suits or
cloth diapers in and I got reusable
toilet paper from my friend Emma's
company final they developed final wipe
final wipe is a reusable antimicrobial
cloth that can be used either wet or dry
when use dry it can replace paper towels
napkins or toilet paper but I would
recommend only using the ones that
you're using
bathroom for that purpose do you have
anything today have you been avoiding it
maybe I'm a little afraid of cold what
if you got the one one then it would be
a different story
maybe we might just try it okay Steve
went to his house to pick up clothes but
I think he just went to go number two do
you use TP at your house what do you do
oh there's no TV anywhere anyway why did
we decide to do this why do we do this I
think that's a question for you maybe
you decided to do this because you're
the one that dragged me well just gettin
is so hard to find rather we were
literally after I installed it he went
online it was like there's warm ones why
can't you get the warm when I went good
wonder where expectant there's no that
expander tomorrow this is your solution
yeah so I'm not actually sure every
useable toilet paper is actually better
for the environment so I'm gonna call my
friend Jessica hi I'm Jessica Aldridge
with adventuresome waste and I have been
working in the waste industry as an
expert for the past 15 years that one
single napkin is going to be thrown away
whereas the reusable is going to be used
multiple times so to really get the cost
of that product we have to take what is
the resource cost what is the greenhouse
gas emissions cost and divide that by
the times that that item has been used
over its lifetime and when you do that a
single-use disposable napkin is going to
have a lot larger environmental
footprint than a reusable napkin is
going to we're not washing that now
by itself so how was the birthday today
that rhymed how was the birthday today
hey how was the birthday today how was
it for you for me oh my god it was
wonderful
but you know was around the corner
what mother's day and I think for
Mother's Day you gave me a warm good day
in this honestly the big day is amazing
I feel like TV is so gross now if you're
smearing poop around it doesn't actually
clean where it's a big day actually
cleans I love it
this whole week you're just gonna shower
after it and I'm going to pick a maybe
this weekend do whatever you like if you
just want to take a shower each time
your Mother's Day gift came early my
reusable toilet favorite I also ordered
reusable toilet paper off at sea they
also call it family cloth on there which
is pretty horrifying it rolls out like
TP there's little buttons just like real
toilet paper oh wow wow this is
incredible guys wow I just got done
using birth day it was actually
pleasantly surprising it wasn't that
cold was like temperature water I still
would prefer out warm water though what
is cool honestly shh don't tell Ari
doesn't know she asleep
what are you filming did you do it I'm
sleeping why then you stay sleep hell
with it
ty you could just do it again maybe what
do you think of the reasonable toilet
paper
it's do you miss toilet paper
yes a little bit yeah I kind of miss it
look to it but I like this new wait I'm
not gonna lie I was being I tripped a
little bit and I want to clean it and I
was like the looking for like paper I
couldn't find it so I is a zero waste
household so I used to grab like the rag
so Joseph way beyond okay I'll keep an
eye out for the hunt
it's getting easier and it's just like a
part of the routine now I'm not like so
tripped up every time every unity go I
agree that far I was still used toilet
paper but you send you month of the day
yeah yeah our using way less toilet and
that's good because then I'm not buying
paper all-time favorite juices Iike the
fragrance I'm gonna have to be extra
careful about how I did this laundry I
usually wash rags that I use and some
paper towels about once a week so I'm
just gonna throw these TP rags in with
them but what I've done is I've soaked
them in Bleach for an hour at first to
disinfect this is series macho detergent
and
leech that I got from sustain high the
extra step of soaking the rags in Bleach
beforehand is a little annoying and
honestly that they clean so well that
nothing comes off on to the reasonable
toilet paper but it's probably just good
to do to this in fact I really like the
reusable TP and of the day which is
really not much of a surprise because
I'm a hippie blah blah but the real
question is will you continue to use
reusable toilet paper or the bidet the
bidet strongly agree maybe change a
reusable toilet paper that's probably
enough for me what about when you're at
my house as long as I'm not doing any of
the cleaning doing well I appreciate
your willingness to try eco-friendly
things with me appreciate it as well
my roommate Danny's currently at her
boyfriend's shelter-in-place
we actually met through her so if she
likes it
I'm gonna continue to do it no I'm at
Arlanda dear fiance